[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tout
bonsoir à tous alors vous n'avez pas le
droit de lever la main mais je vais vous
demander d'applaudir qui depuis ce matin
a eu une sacrée idée merci qui depuis ce
matin à concrétiser cette idée très peu
à ce que je vois alors on va essayer de
comprendre pourquoi vous n'avez
peut-être pas concrétiser votre idée
peut-être avez-vous laissé place à votre
ego qui vous a dit ton idée n'est pas
bonne ou peut-être avez-vous laissé
place à votre raison qui vous a murmuré
à l'oreille que votre idée elle était
nulle ou comme moi avez vous développé
une superbe façon de terre vos idées la
première idée que j'ai eue
pour ma part ça a été de mettre une
bouteille de coca vide sur les rayons de
mon vélo
est ce que tout le monde voit le bruit
que cela fait ce fameux burger
me voilà donc sur le guidon de ma moto
ma harley davidson et je monte et je
descends la ruelle jusqu'au moment où
stoppe ma famille me demande tout
simplement d'arrêter de faire du bruit
est aussi d'arrêter de faire des bêtises
à ce moment là je me suis dit est ce que
toutes mes idées vont être des bêtises
et j'ai senti un étouffement en moi
comme si on m'avait dit mais natacha
toutes les idées vont être des bêtises
tu ne vas pas aller au bout ce même
étouffement je les ressentis à l'école
le système scolaire tels que moi je l'
ai connu le professeur nous donner une
information
je n'ai pas le droit de rire je n'ai pas
le droit de pleurer je n'ai pas le droit
de communiquer je n'ai pas le droit
d'échanger
je dois me taire et recevoir
l'information soyons réalistes vous
rappelez des cadeaux de fête des mères
que l'on faisait ou le cadeau de fête
des pères est ce que concrètement avez
vous laissé place à toute votre idée à
ce moment là pour ma part que ce soit la
tasse que ce soit la plante ou que ce
soit le poème je ne me je ne me suis
jamais
vu dans ces cadeaux tout simplement ils
étaient imposées par le professeur alors
avec tous et étouffement
je me sentais vraiment très très mal à
l'école est d'autant plus que je suis
entré avec une légère différence
les professeurs et mes parents avaient
décrété que j'étais à haut potentiel et
je le mets bien entre guillemets alors
quand on m'a appris que j'allais sauter
de classe je me voyais pouvoir lever le
doigt et par les pouvoir exprimer mes
idées pouvoir exprimer tout ce que
j'avais en moi j'arrive le premier jour
dans la classe des grands
et dès que j'ouvre ma bouche j'entends
c'est bon on attache à tétouan on le
sais tu que tu connais tu connais point
avec ses 3 étouffement que ce soit à la
maison que ce soit avec le professeur
que ce soit avec mes camarades je me
sentais de plus en plus mal et j'ai
appris finalement à éteindre ces petites
lumières qui venait dans mon cerveau
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'une idée une
idée
c'est une représentation intellectuelle
selon le larousse
je vais pas aller chercher dans la
définition est selon un professeur en
psychologie il dit lorsque vous partagez
votre idée vous êtes déjà dans le
subconscient vous êtes déjà en train de
le réaliser
sauf que moi à l'école on m'avait dit de
me taire et c'est ce que j'ai fait
pendant tout mon cursus scolaire je
réussis donc mes diplômes et j'arrive à
saint denis
j'ai 19 ans je suis indépendante je ne
suis plus à l'école
je ne suis plus fumer par an tout va
bien je vais pouvoir développer mes
idées je rencontre un homme cet homme
deviendra mon concubin pendant quatre
ans et pendant quatre ans cet homme
avide et vider de tout sens vidé de
méconnaissance vidé de mes compétences
vidé de mes qualités et de mes valeurs
au delà du complexe d'infériorité qui
m'a fait sentir durant ces quatre ans il
a réussi
à me faire asseoir sur ses idées à lui
sur ses opinions
je reproduisais des choses que je
n'aurais jamais fait avant je vivais au
travers de lui mais je ne vivais pas au
travers de moi je ne pourrais même pas
vous dire quel livre j'ai lu durant ces
quatre ans puisque j'en ai bu autant
cette période là était un peu creuse
pour moi plus du tout d'idées je me
trompe
j'avais quand même des pensées
intrusives qui arrivait à mon cerveau
savez ce genre de pensée qui vous dit tu
sais quoi natacha ça sert à rien d'être
là c'était des idées noires
j'avais qu'une seule envie c'était de
disparaître au bout de ces quatre ans me
voilà donc le 23 novembre sur le rebord
d'une fenêtre
très vite je dois trouver une idée de
génie
une idée qui doit me sauver la vie je
suis sur le rebord de cette fenêtre je
regarde en bas et là tout doucement la
machine se remet en marche
j'ai un calcul qui revient dans ma tête
qui me dit ok vu ton poids tu fais
exactement 60 kg en ce temps là le seul
il est très bas après j'ai connu qu'il
était à 9 m la fenêtre était à 9 m si
j'arrive en bas quelles seraient les
conséquences
je décide de poursuivre mon idée et je
passe au dessus de cette fenêtre
me voilà neuf mètres plus bas mes pieds
touchent le sol et je ne me suis pas
relevé c'était une très mauvaise idée
je me suis fracturé les deux talons le
tibia et le péroné et en plus j'ai eu
droit à cinq mois d'allaitement
mais cette idée m'a complètement sauver
car durant ces cinq mois j'ai pu
retrouver en moi l' envie d'aller
m'intéresser au monde
l' envie de regarder la télé de lire des
livres de m'intéresser au monde qui
m'entoure et pendant ces sept mois je
fais un terrible constat je suis en
fauteuil roulant mes déplacements sont
extrêmement limités chambre toilettes
salle de bain cuisine
fois je suis plein de vie j'ai envie de
vivre et d'aller dehors et je suis
limité dans mon domicile
du moins je sais papa et maman puisque
je suis de retour dans le cocon familial
et puis je me souviens que j'avais eu
une première idée c'était de transformer
mon vélo en une moto et là entre mes
mains
j'ai un fauteuil roulant je vous sens
sourire je sais que vous êtes en train
de vous dire qu'est ce qu'elle a fait je
regarde mon fauteuil roulant et je me
dis ok je vais aller dehors et à côté de
chez mon papa il ya une pente de 7 %
vous voyez la pente de la route des
tamarins au bout il ya un virage c'était
le même type de pente au bouquin virage
et je me suis dit ok natacha tu vas
prendre cette pente avec ton fauteuil
roulant tu vas y aller et puis je
commence à réfléchir et je me dis la
vérité calcul il était vraiment nul un
preuve en est là cette fois ci il faut y
aller donc je me dis si c'est moi qui
impulsent eu la force mon fauteuil
roulant il sera telle vitesse et dans le
virage peut-être que je pourrai jamais
si c'est ma soeur qui me pousse avec le
fauteuil roulant vu la vitesse où je
vais arriver je dois tout de suite
réfléchir à qu'est ce que je vais dire
aux médecins pour lui dire que je suis
désolé j'ai plus de jambes du tout en
fait je réfléchis je réfléchis je vais
rechercher et dans la maison secrètement
dans le couloir je m'entraîne à aller
très vite avec mon fauteuil roulant et à
freiner d'un coup le jour j arrive je
prétexte avec ma seule envie de sortir
et de prendre l'air et me ramène en haut
de la pente et au moment jeudi un regard
qui est un papillon heureuse je lâche le
fauteuil roulant et me voilà dévalant
toute la pente
je vois le virage arrivé et je me dis
natacha il est temps de vérifier si ton
idée elle était la bonne et donc en
moins il y avait cette chaleur qui monte
et qui me disait ça y est c'est reparti
la machine elle est en route
j'arrive dans le virage et j'ai freiné
avec les mains mauvaise idée
encore une fois je me suis brûlé les
mains mais au bout il n'y avait eu ni ma
famille ni ma soeur ni mon professeur ni
qui que ce soit pour me dire stop
je suis allé au bout de mon idée
rebooster de toute cette énergie
je me sentais plein à avoir plein
d'autres idées et un jour pendant que je
prends ma douche puisque c'est le lieu
où j'ai le plus d'idées je fais le
constat que ça y est j'ai quitté mon
fauteuil roulant
j'ai quitté mes plâtre et je dois
retourner au boulot malheureusement je
peux pas rester debout plus de ce
secteur puisque mes gens ne sont pas en
capacité de me supporter encore et je me
dis mes attaches à créer son entreprise
tout simplement sauf que je sais dans
quel secteur je veux aller mais je
connais pas comment créer une entreprise
alors avec mes béquilles me voilà dans
la rue de paris à aller faire des
allers-retours avec la cci et faire des
formations
je vais partir je vais aller à des
conférences je vais me rendre dans des
séminaires je vais échanger je vais lire
et je vais aller au bout de mon idée
neuf mois plus tard me voilà avec mes
petits papiers devant le bâtiment de ma
structure de mon entreprise pour moi
j'avais abouti encore une fois à une
idée aujourd'hui je continue à prendre
des douches évidemment comme tout le
monde
et à chaque fois que je suis sous la
douche j'ai à chaque fois une idée et je
regrette de ne pas avoir de carnets
waterproof pour tout noter donc celle
que j'apprenne bien dans mon cerveau je
me dépêche de m'habiller je cours au
bureau et je dis généralement délit lors
elle j'ai une idée est très souvent mon
équipe partage l'idée avec moi ce
sourire que je vois sur leur visage me
fait tellement du bien de me dire que
finalement je peux partager mon idée et
elle ne me le diront pas stop
non pas parce que je suis leur patronne
mais tout simplement parce qu'elle croit
vraiment en ses idées
donc pour résumer avoir une idée c'est
génial je suis sûr que depuis ce matin
vous en avez eu des superbes idées
passer à la concrétisation
je sais que ça peut être autre chose
mais ne faites pas comme moi
ne dévoilait pas une pente ne vous
prenez pas une fenêtre pour vous dire ça
y est j'ai une idée tout va bien croyez
en vous soyez authentique avec vous même
aller au bout de vos idées et ne laisser
personne censure et vos idées
merci d'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]